i was having a lot of fatigue and body
aches i just thought it was exhaustion
from traveling but the next morning i
woke up with rashes all over my hands
the lesions started spreading to the
more usual suspect areas
so that really
made the doctors sort of confirm that
what i had was
monkey pox
kevin kawang believes he was first
infected in late june
about a month after monkey pox cases
began to be reported in the u.s
it was sort of this like mystery disease
i think i approached things cautiously
but at the same time i wasn't even sure
what to be aware of
by late july the world health
organization declared it a global health
emergency their highest level of alert
it will not be the next covet 19
pandemic but as a public health
professional i am very worried about
what's unfolding because this has the
possibility to become a new virus that
circulates regularly so how does monkey
pox spread and what can be done to
contain this outbreak
it's called monkey pox because it was
first detected in research monkeys and
because it's closely related to smallpox
the way i think about smallpox it's the
human version of monkeypox it's not
engineered to exploit human cells and
human bodies we're like an accidental
host monkeypox is endemic to parts of
africa where it mostly circulates among
rodents occasionally from close
interactions like hunting or eating
monkey pox will spread from an animal to
a human and in may of 2022 someone
showing symptoms traveled from nigeria
to the united kingdom
soon after other cases began appearing
in the uk then portugal sweden the u.s
previously the outbreaks were fairly
limited epidemiologists were able to
bring it under control in the current
outbreak it's spreading fairly
efficiently between humans primarily
through sexual contact
when infected monkey pox gets into your
bloodstream and creates lesions on the
skin while it can spread through
respiratory droplets or bodily fluids
with this 2022 outbreak it's rare the
most common way it spreads is through
skin-to-skin contact with those lesions
we know that during intimate contact or
cuddling etc you make these micro
abrasions in the skin you can't really
see it a lot of times but they're there
so the virus just jumps from the person
who has it and there's tons of it
into one of these micro abrasions
once infected it can take a while for
symptoms to appear that can happen as
soon as five days after infection to
nearly three weeks after but they
usually appear around here
and these first few days of symptoms
look like a typical illness as your
immune system kicks in to begin fighting
the disease fever headache fatigue and
even the swelling of your lymph nodes
it's after that that the rash and
legions typically begin especially on
the hands and face
with the outbreak that began in 2022 the
lesions appeared differently they can be
localized more on the genitals and even
appear more like bumps something that
not all medical professionals are
trained to identify even when i went
into urgent care they told me that this
was definitely not monkey pox because
the way that monkey pox had been
appearing in photos that they've
received were larger lesions umbilicated
so kind of like donut shaped all
throughout the body and i just didn't
have any of that at the time
people thought to have visible rashes
like what you'd see in the textbooks
with these huge boils and people's arms
but they could be very very subtle dr
chinwang was able to diagnose and
prescribe kevin t pox an anti-viral
medication that the government already
had stockpiled there was a lot of
preparedness particularly after the
september 11th attacks and the anthrax
mailings that went into preparing for
smallpox we had a lot of tools already
in the arsenal to fight smallpox but
that also worked for monkeypox the
stockpile includes an approved vaccine
us authorities are testing already made
doses and ordering 2.5 million more
and so we are in a relatively good
position against this virus than we
would be against a virus that we had
never
prepared for before but we need to make
sure that we use those tools
appropriately and aggressively in order
to bring this virus under control the
vaccine can also be used as part of the
treatment if given within four days
after the exposure it can prevent the
infection or at least make it less
severe you can like develop your
antibodies because it it's like so slow
it's because it's trying to find a rat
and it's a human the vaccines to come
available have been restricted to the
community monkeypox is affecting most
men who have sex with men among the 6000
cases currently reported to the world
health organization 98 are in men who
have sex with men but we also want to be
very careful not to stigmatize the
disease or to give the impression that
it is exclusively and forever limited to
men who have sex with men because that's
not the case it's a human virus it can
attack
anyone
public health officials are concerned
about the virus spreading to other
vulnerable groups like children or even
u.s animals
which is why the messaging is the same
as the last outbreak we saw
stop the spread and get vaccinated